عهد جديد لطاقه لا تنتهي كلمات وصفت اطلاق
هذه المحطه شمال بلجيكا سبعينيات القرن
الماضي اليوم ياتي هذا المفاعل النووي
كبديل في واجهه ازمه الطاقه الاوروبيه مع
روسيا
ينتج الاتحاد الاوروبي حاليا اقل من نصف
احتياجاته من خلال الطاقه النوويه والغاز
الطبيعي والفحم والطاقه المائيه والرياح
والطاقه الشمسيه
الاستخدام الجيد والمعتدل للموارد التي
لدينا بالاضافه الى المصادر البديله مثل
طاقه الرياح والطاقه الشمسيه والمحطات
النوويه جعلتنا قادرين على مواجهه الازمه
كنا قبل الحرب نعتمد على شركائنا في
النرويج لاجل الغاز واليوم طورنا علاقاتنا
معهم وكذلك توسعنا في استخدام المصادر
البديله
وامام ازمه الطاقه الناجمه عن الحرب في
اوكرانيا لم يحقق الاتحاد الاوروبي اجماعا
في فرض عقوباته على روسيا اذ عارضها بعض
الاعضاء كالمجر وبلغاريا مما اعطاهما
استثناءات
لكن الاتحاد مضى في التحرك بما يعطيه من
الاعتماد على روسيا واثق
قمنا بزياده مستويات التخزين لدينا قبل
عام كان تخزين الغاز في جميع انحاء اوروبا
منخفضا جدا سيكون لدينا دائما بوليصه
التامين ضد اي تخفيضات في العرض وتمكنا من
استبدال جميع الشحنات الغاز التي قطعتها
روسيا واعتمدنا على واردات الغاز الطبيعي
المسال من شركاء مختلفين بعضهم في الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا والولايات المتحده
فرض الاتحاد جمله من العقوبات على روسيا
منذ الصيف 2022 لاول مره شملت مصادر
الطاقه وقطاعه تكنولوجيا والاستثمار فيهما
هو اذا طريق سلكه الاتحاد الاوروبي في
اتجاه مستقبلي لا يعرف ماله بمازق الطاقه
تجد اوروبا نفسها بين مستقبل تسعى فيه
لاعتماد مصادر بديله وبينماض ترتبط فيه
بشريك تركته دون رجعه وبين هذا وذاك واقع
سياسي واقتصادي جديد يجعل من فتره ما بعد
الحرب ليس كما قبلها عبد الله الشامي
الجزيره